first of all I'm not gay
second of all it shouldn't make a
difference if I was or if I wasn't the
focus should be on the music not my
sexuality Sean took to snapchat to get
his message out and the 17 year old told
us this past Sunday that he's getting
more comfortable with speaking up for
himself I'm talking a lot more about
growing up and matured you know content
and like it's just I have a lot more to
say I've lived a year of the craziest
life ever so I have to talk about it
Shawn had a huge hit last year with
stitches and his new single treat you
better is moving up the charts
and Shawn knows he has great fans out
there that show him major support they
know pretty much everything about me
they'd actually know more about me than
I know about me but with yesterday's
video Shawn wants to make clear that
he's not hiding his sexuality
now I'm not frustrated because people
were saying that it was gay at all I
have no problem with that because it
wouldn't make a difference to me I'm
frustrated because in this day and age
people have the audacity to to write
online that I'm gay as if it were a bad
thing but he knows exactly what he wants
in a girlfriend opening up to notion
magazine in March he says he really
likes brunettes and dancers and I really
like funny girls girls with a witty
sense of humor so if someone is able to
catch on to what I'm saying very quickly
I find that very attractive